[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
happy tuesday you tapped into the group
chat live
in the bluetooth report app presented by
fanduel
cj mccombs back marcus smart is back
carousel fur
is back and your favorite big three is
back my name is kathy richards our
betting expert and
sniper is in the middle of our screen
that is kelly stewart
and his sunset vibes worked magically
for the los angeles lakers against his
warriors last night
greg ivory that's how you start off the
show cabbie
yeah sunset vibes that's your thing
sunset vibes except that you gave it to
braun and another triple-double last
night that that's bad
vibes i need sunsets in the comments
right now because abby just started to
show off with bad vibes we need we need
sunsets let's go
okay we love that you um tap into the
group chat
on this show every week but now we've
opened the group chat 24
7. the new community stream so you're
already on blues report
open the app go to um
sports betting and then click on
community you will see this graphic
in the on on your phone we need your
your locks your picks your dogs of the
day
your your betting text messages with
your homies
or your mom your freakout videos
everything post your betting slips we'd
love to see it and we want to share
in uh that whole experience so the group
chat is open 24 7. so come rock with us
um the 3x2 by the way is still scorching
america as the best
bet in sports thank you fanduel
all right so we rock with this bet every
week
and uh because it's tuesday i want to um
reemphasize that
it is three by tuesday i'm sorry kels
before i get going
i forgot about the uh the group chat
have you fired off your picks tonight
in uh in our group chat i got excited
about the three by two i apologize in
the community chat we're gonna start
working on that a little bit going
forward you guys i got a lot of stuff on
my plate i'm actually multitasking right
now
trying to figure out uh what i'm gonna
bet tonight so you guys go back to
arguing about sunset vibe so i can find
some winners
okay next plus seven i like it um
so the three by two it's three by
tuesday
so salute to our friends at fanduel who
eat every tuesday and thursdays
you get to um place this bet last week
we went with uh the brooklyn nets and uh
geez what was the g money you were so yo
the brooklyn nets and the boston celtics
we were one joe harris bounce away on a
three-point shot from hitting the three
by two
unfortunately we didn't but we're back
at it tonight
earlier on social we put a post up on
twitter
there are two games tonight on tnt
schedule
we have the celtics and the jazz and the
blazers and the pelicans
we asked you which game is gonna hit
which three by two would you like
the audience so far is leaning
with 56 percent of the vote with new or
57
of the vote new orleans and portland
zion
lonzo the return of cj mccullum
and of course if it's game time it's
game time
that's the match up you're leading
towards g money uh
tap in with your army how they feeling
about these matchups i like that kevi if
it's game time it's game time
yes i like that uh you guys know what
time it is you guys need to get in the
comments and let me know
which 3x2 are we riding are we rocking
with the jazz
versus the uh celtics or are we rocking
with new orleans
versus portland and daming them y'all
let me know
get in the comments get creative uh
which one are we riding with
kelly yep
i ask you this every week i ask you
i'ma switch it up i'm gonna switch it up
today which one are you picking today
which one instead of
are you riding kelly which one which
game you think is going to hit
this line it only took like 12 weeks but
greg's finally got it we've been over
this
fanduel gives off free money i don't
think you can go wrong with either these
picks
but how can you not take the pels in
portland
the pels are the worst three-point
defense
in the nba they're gonna give up two
buckets
they may even get a bucket themselves we
may see three
here in the first couple of minutes i'm
excited i think there's no defense by
either side
makes this one the easier of the two but
don't count out uh utah and boston
maybe a fanduel maybe they'll let me uh
parlay them what do you guys think oh
now you're talking our language kells i
think actually the total in that game is
is either i think it's 239 so it's way
up there
tonight it's the return of cj mccullum
uh so you know maybe he'll even maybe
he'll take the first shot maybe he'll
score the first
hit the first three-pointer on the other
side lonzo ball has been getting it
started
for the pelicans so for sure i i love
that game as well the late night
game portland and new orleans i love the
three by two for sure
two three-point shots will be made in
the first three minutes
of that game g-money are you are you
riding with kel's and i
uh kevin let me get into these comments
first all right and then i'm gonna let
them uh
right i mean decide for me because you
know i am a man of the people
i got um i got hold on the comments are
jumping
i got mli both 13 says damon zion is
must see tv
you guys see the gif right there zion
flexing shout out to you
you are walking away with the hoodie uh
here we go
maxwell rexella maxwell rexella's in the
comments
and he is rocking with the pelicans the
pelicans
and uh the blazers tonight shout out to
you max yes actually has a funny gift if
you guys want to see it's the pelican
walking into the tent
that's pretty funny um where is that
even from
how many how many pages did he have to
scroll down in the gift list to find
that to find that one i know right
and billa raza billariza 94
says new orleans versus portland
riding he is riding he said let's ride
greg let's ride you know we are riding
we are always writing the yes
yost dude 15. i'll give you a hoodie you
said uh jazz
he said jazz shout out to you yos dude
everybody that i mentioned you're also
walking away with hoodie just want to
let you know
but uh i think i got a rock with you
guys we got game time
yeah you know we got dame we got cj
coming back
you know we we we got new orleans and
and and b
ingram zion maybe you can pop a three i
just see it's it's
shooters are all over the court in that
game cavi and kelly mentioned defense
i'm taking that game
so uh let's ride so check out team
ticket
yes first time ever we have consensus
here
uh check out br betting socials for the
link to fanduel to get the three by two
odds boost
do that immediately uh tonight the nba
leading
utah jazz are in boston for a great
matchup
and two all-stars are going head-to-head
that's donovan mitchell and jayson tatum
the last time they played
donovan mitchell outscored jayson tatum
36-23
but tonight's a new night tonight's a
new game and they are going head-to-head
again so we're asking you
who will score more points donovan
mitchell
or jason tatum that is the question
g-money
uh i threw it out there are there any
gifts in the
in the comments right away as they heard
that mitchell
versus tatum enderman enderman has the
donovan mitchell gift going
all right let me do something if you
want to decide or if you have a take on
who's going to score more points tonight
get in the comments and give me a gift
of the player that you are riding with i
need to see gifts and gifts
only is it donovan mitchell or is it
jason tatum
kelly which way are you leaning are you
looking at that plus money or
are you laying the chalk i just had to
pull it up to confirm because i didn't
want to be wrong here but jason tatum
has over the last four games 27 21 31
and 23 on the flip side if you look at
donovan
he's kind of struggled a little bit it's
been a little bit of a roller coaster
ride
i think this is kind of a coin flip
scenario where yes either guy could win
but i think it's gonna be within one or
two points
so yes of course i'm gonna take the plus
money when we're getting
plus 140 on a coin flip remember greg we
went over this on the super bowl
yeah but was it tails number coins it's
always tails never fails isn't it
it was heads gabby there was ah yeah
i also had the chiefs too so that didn't
work out so well for me but listen
the jazz are on a little bit of a slide
they've lost five of the last six road
games
they're in boston but this is a bounce
back game this is a bounce back
opportunity for donovan mitchell
who is a great shooter marcus smart
makes his return or has made his return
for the boston celtics and he is
boston's best
defender but he's on a minutes
restriction he might play
22 24 minutes so donovan mitchell
might get clamped a little bit but he's
still going to have room to operate so
i'm saying
mitchell tonight 20 i put it in the
comments already 27 points
uh d geek the homie who's always rocking
with us on group chat
he's like it's going to be 27 plus in my
opinion so d
geek and i don mitchell to outscore uh
jayson tatum g money where are you
leaning on this head-to-head matchup
cabbie let me get in the comments and i
you know i gotta rock with my people
lucito lucito says tatum's hearing all
of those don
picks and uh he got the gift with tatum
making a face
uh you you guys yeah he's making the
face looking at him like what what are
you talking about
shout out to you lucito uh richie 21 got
the donovan mitchell gift he is laughing
in the gift like
this is too easy this is literally too
easy there it is
i got uh one more for you cabbie and
then i'm gonna decide
e e 96 is rocking with jayson tatum you
got the jayson tatum gift praying
uh there it is for you guys to see at
home oh hold on i gotta get this down
i i hold on i gotta get this there it is
there it is there it is
greg on camera everything's backwards
man
all right so uh i said one more but
cabbie you know the
the people are they're they're filling
up the comments i gotta give one more
hoodie
raider909 i've i've grown i'm not gonna
lie i've grown since i've
been here at bleacher report if anything
said raider on it i would not have even
read it before i got here but now you
know
i'm here so uh and i'm i'm a guy of love
i love to spread the love so raider909
you rocking with donovan mitchell shout
out to you you're also rocking
walking away with the hoodie but cavi so
who are you choosing bro you went like
three tatums and three spider mitchells
i'm getting there i'm feeling the vibes
from raider i was going to get there
see the growth in greg it's the growth
and greg right here
on the show uh i'm rocking with raider
i'm rocking with raider i'm rocking with
donovan mitchell he's the alpha he's the
alpha of that team
he's the alpha of that team jason tatum
has a batman i mean he has a robin he's
batman he has a robin
donovan mitchell has rudy gobert
yeah rudy gobert is a defender he
rebounds
i'm talking about on the offensive side
yeah and mike connolly okay and jordan
clarkson okay
and royce o'neal yup those are those are
those are those are options those are
but they're not
no they're not no uh uh from the celtics
brown they're not him
what's his name okay yeah jalen brown
jaylen brown i don't know why that
didn't pop up to my they're not jaylen
brown i'll tell you that much
everybody you just named isn't a jalen
brown okay you mentioned
you mentioned you're growing g-money but
we know that
the amount that you bet is shrinking
because
we we just unveiled this worst bettors
tournament and
uh one of the guys one of them is uh
what is it that you you don't actually
bet so
i know you said donovan mitchell are you
actually putting money on donald
mitchell tonight
am i actually putting money on donovan
mitchell yeah tonight
why not gabby we are riding i put money
on them i put money on a three by two
every time i get a chance to
i'll put money on it right now right now
if you want me to right now cabbie
right now let's get in there
we spent uh we spent the first half of
of the nba season singing the praises of
lebron
and nicole yokic and joelle embiid and
giannis anto takumpo
but james harden has wedged his way into
the mvp discourse the mvp chat
he's in everybody's group chat because
of his recent play
with the brooklyn nets so much so
that he's in the conversation now let's
update the odds as far as the mvp
discussion goes
braun had his fourth triple-double of
the season in a blowout win
against the uh warriors last night he is
back to being the betting favorite to
win
his fifth nba mvp jokic is right that
has now moved back into the number two
spot at plus 230
and in b because he's out with a knee
injury for two to three weeks
he is slid down the list at plus 600
and we know that this isn't uh this is a
regular season award
but brian gets praise because he wins in
the playoffs
and giannis wins in the regular season
but then he gets
um you know he gets criticized because
he doesn't win
in the postseason so giannis is still
down there plus sixteen hundred
uh g-money james and james harden has
entered the mvp
chat now are you gonna sprinkle on
hardin
and uh and double up on your mvp beth
because
earlier you said kevin durant is your
guy
no it's simple not going to do that
kathy actually i want the people
i want the people in the comments to
tell me what they think
tell me who you are writing tell me who
you will put your money on for this mvp
race
and then i'll tell you uh my take heavy
then i'll i'll get there
i gotta let the people speak first then
i'll come but kelly
are you switching it up this time are
you what are you doing are you are you
switching it up
are you throwing darts a bet yet just
like i told you guys you can't make a
bet on some of these guys once they're
already
like well known once are on this sheet
here look at james harden
a couple of weeks ago we talked about
him and kathy's like kel do you think
he's worth the bet
i said no if you ask me today of course
he's worth the bet the dude
is a man on a mission he has taken over
on this net's offense but the value's
now gone
james harden is making himself a nice
campaign lebron has given himself a nice
campaign all year but you can't bet him
at plus 150.
if you have a preseason ticket on luca
you had terrible odds and get way better
odds now but luca's not going to win in
vp
then you got the joker the nuggets
aren't going to go that far in the west
i don't think that a nuggets player is
going to win mvp so here i am getting
all red
and flustered and angry because this is
too hard to bet
point blank period the end so i'm going
way down this deep dark rabbit hole
uh kathy and i do an nba betstream
on mondays and thursdays and it's super
awesome
with some of the guys from fanduel tom
vecchio's great
tim doyle's great and they got in a
heated debate the other night
and next thing you know they're
convincing me that i need to bet on
chris
paul to win mvp now hear me
it's a long shot that is now hear me out
it is
such a long shot and he's not gonna win
in vp
but listen to me when i say that there
is some value that he's still
quietly flying under the writer this
dude was 500
to one not that long ago he wasn't even
in the conversation now the odds have
dropped in half why
because the suns are going to win the
pacific division they may be able to
hang tight in the west and who are they
going to be able to do that because
of the best player on their team chris
paul and also might i add
that i found out this little nugget one
of the best ats
teams was the oklahoma city thunder with
chris paul
now this year one of the best ats teams
is the phoenix suns
with chris paul i don't know man i'm
just saying chris paul
makes us a lot of money maybe he's worth
a little tiny baby sprinkle you put 10
bucks on this you're getting back 2400
bones
yeah that's that's a lot hey salutes
everybody who's got who rocks with the
suns against the spread
um there's only been one mvp in
nba history who was one playing less
than 80
of the games and that was bill walton in
1978. joel embiid who was
in the discourse for the past two three
weeks
was like embiid is gonna win mvp you
know he's gonna miss two or three weeks
so the max number of games that he can
play if we project is 55 of the 72 so
that's
under 80 his availability is gonna
sort of reflect or affect his mvp
chances
nicola jokic who i've been on all season
has played all 39 games
just dropped 32 and 14 against the
pacers last night
that's my guy but kels james harden as
we just saw in that graphic can we
get the graphic back up please is plus
1600
i'm sprinkling on james harden 10 triple
doubles
as a brooklyn net he's been absolutely a
man on fire
uh yeah sorry plus 1300
there's still some value there so uh
yeah that that's where i'm rocking
g money you had money on durant earlier
this season
and you say you're not sprinkling on
james harden like don't you want to
improve your chances because
kevin durant hasn't played in a month
and there's little to no chance he's
going to win mvp this year yeah
as well mike chris paul tickets going to
cash before his kevin durant to get
cashes
yep kd's uh he's hurt you know so
he's probably not going gonna win mvp
but uh let me get into these comments
because you know i gotta talk i gotta i
gotta get
i gotta get my my my fuel from the
people from the people raider909 he's
rocking with you cabbie and the joker
uh ben the goat ben the goat shout out
to you he's rocking with joel
embiid joel and beat not zion
gotta agree with kelly kelly you're
getting some love for that chris paul
pick shout out shout out to you not zion
it's not gonna win but you know what it
might be fun to like
have him get into the conversation at
that point in time like i would feel
really good
with my 100 ticket to win 24 grand at
that point in time
avedia avedia avedia 18
says yeah what a james harden gift
shouts out to you avedia
i got one more cabbie one more in me
spartan drew 87
spartan drew 87 says embiid for
mvp uh no one in the comments has my guy
cabbie
no one in the comments has my guy early
on i was all over katie
all over katie as i should have been
he's the best player when healthy
in the nba then kd got
hurt and i said uh there's a guy by the
name of dame lillard that plays in
portland and he's a win
streak away from being in the mvp
conversation
well guess what cabbie portland's uh
towards the top
of the west the western conference and
uh
my guy my guy dame he's been balling so
guess what instead of throwing darts
and and and picking different players
every week like you do gabby yeah
and strategy and kelly i'm gonna stay
consistent i'm gonna stay consistent
here
and stay with my pick dane lillard uh
he's a win streak away he's a win streak
how much are you gonna put on dame
lillard
he's a winch i already own them i
already put it on them
already how much did you put how much
did you bet on them 50
cabbie 15 50 hairs cabs
i'm not going to unichain because i
still make twenty five dollar
bets you taught jazz at boston but fifty
success
i would love to see that on your phone
just for the record because i don't
believe that you bet anymore however
let's move on um and and maybe this is
the reason why because
says you have a standing 500 bet with
kelly stewart
to hit a five leg same game parlay and
uh your results this season are like a
kyle kuzma free throw
my dude uh 0 for 11. and
um we have another opportunity
baseball season is around the corner
i've got an opportunity to step up to
bat
and uh and knock one out of the park i
will give you credit on this one though
you were one assist shy one hitting
the five like par lately 500 from kelly
one assist when we pull up the graphic
do you guys see that
you guys see more oh yeah i see you're
five to one
on a five teamer that should pay at
least 22 to one
i see green i only see this right here
is called karma
i'm not even
[Music]
thanks to your favorite player i like it
not even worried about what kelly's
talking about all i see is green here
with the x that was barely barely there
by uh one assist
okay so tonight we're locking in the
utah jazz
versus the boston celtics celtics are
rolling right now they've won five of
their last six
so if you have more celtics on this
ticket maybe you'll maybe you'll get all
five
check marks g money the floor is yours
build this parlay sir
let's go this is what we've been waiting
for this is the
week this is the day we take kelly's
money
i am so happy for this i was texting the
producer early
because i was like hey greg this is the
day we are gonna take
you're gonna leave my 500 bucks just to
break even we're gonna we're trash
parliament we're gonna get there we're
gonna get there starting it off
starting it off the guy i forgot his
name earlier i don't know why he went to
cal which is down the street
jaylen brown my guy jaylen brown
uh he's gonna score 15 points or over
locking that in jaylen brown to score 15
points over is a lot reasonable
lock that in all right moving on moving
on
jason tatum jason tatum
to score 15 points or more lock that in
that is
awesome when his uh total is like 21 and
a half
what is this like minus four dollars
kelly you were really smart to know that
his total was 21.
man jesus here we go moving on
moving on donovan mitchell donovan
mitchell
cabbie i mean what you said
you said 20 points you said donovan was
going to have a game today
25 plus you said he was going to have
more than you know greg ben like
ten ten plus points
donovan mitchell to score 20 plus points
no no
put some respect on that man's name he's
going to get over 20 today
easy easy easy and then we're going to
move over to possibly the sixth man of
the year
jordan carter another another guy that
you mentioned
uh when you were trying to say that the
jazz players were better than
uh jaylen brown which is not
not i understand don mitchell also has
help he doesn't he's not rudy gobert
could be a batman
you know in in the in that analogy
between jayson tatum and jaylen brown
donald mitchell rudy bigger grow bear
but please continue yeah yeah y'all
jordan clarkson here we go
do you have 20 plus 25 plus where are
you going go get go get 10.
why not go get 10. 10. jordan that's a
walk in the park for jordan clarkson of
course you can get ten
yeah yeah this part lays over you think
it's gonna pay like seven to one watch
gabby
this parlay's a walk in the park and we
got mike connolly
all right here we go coming in at a
smooth
minus eight thousand mike connolly
what mine is what is it two
assists and over
or two assists go go grab two assists
let's go grab two assists coming in at a
smooth
minus eight thousand i need smooth in
the comments
what that's even an option to assist
like how is that even an optional
fanduel i stopped paying attention to
you i'm trying to find nba winners
tonight
this is just like hey let's pull up i
need a new job anybody out there
want to give me a new job um let's see
i'm really good at cooking
what come on come on this is in real
life
this is not real life this is the
winning ticket this is how
we're going to see one go through the
basket here kelly's going to send me a
venmo or a cash app
your ever uh mind minus 143 on a
five-teamer
kelly great chad johnson child please
hey kelly kelly i'll give you the
opportunity i'm done listening i'm going
to get your peace out
you guys
she took her hair piece out i'm a guy of
love i was going to say she can cash out
for 4.99
i can't hear you my earpiece is on the
ground you're giving her the cash out
option
cash out for 4.95 99
right now kelly you can do that you're
gonna watch this later
you're gonna watch re-watch this i'm
giving you the option cash out right now
just cash out
has there ever been a parlay in the
history of parlays that offers
negative like minus odds it was minus
143 greg
this is a lock gabby it's a loss can we
sign off it's a lot big piece
i'm ready for my money kelly i am ready
for my money
uh wait tell us if this one happens
wow she's on record saying she's not
gonna pay me how am i gonna pay you when
you have a five team or minus 143
that should be 22 to one i said you
wouldn't base the five team or how a
five teamer works
is everything's at least minus 110 or
better that's how this works
but that's cool we can go round and
round and round and round and i'm gonna
write this
down when i have my one-on-one and
everybody goes kelly why are you unhappy
at work
because i got some shites yeah uh i
can't say that on the show i got some
sheisty
uh people that i work with that i don't
really like
kelly i mean that's your fault you're
the one that made the okay
yeah you made the bet every everybody
saw you made the bed i mean it's tape
it's recorded it's on youtube
you can go look it up it's on the brf
you made the bet and now you're mad that
you made the bet and you're trying
i'm mad that i made the bet that you
and max are what is max's job i don't
even know what does he do around here
anyway that you and max decided oh here
here's how we're gonna get kelly
great idea well guess what i played the
long game here you can have your 500
bucks and i'll just never talk to you
again
so when they say kelly what would you
like to do for the next year at bleacher
report i'm like well you know what i
just can't work with guys like greg
we just don't have that vibe you know
i mean i guess so i guess so i don't
know if the audience will like that
though
thank you thank you for joining our
family therapy session here on
we evidently have some things that we
have to work out uh
amongst ourselves remember what you
learned here today um
the details of a bet between friends are
always fluent but also
mikey mikey's in the comments talking
team kelly mikey we're done i need
somebody in the comments we're doing
three by two
live on be our betting mikey we're done
we're done we're popular
by greg we're done hashtag greg public
mikey it's over
it's over what you learned here today
sometimes sometimes breakups happen live
on television
uh the group chat is open in the
community
twenty-five
friendships friendships friends i can't
believe you might have been picking and
i believe you mikey come on gabby
cannot believe you might be live cannot
believe you mikey
i'm switzerland i'm also canada i'm
neutral
thanks for tapping into the group chat
presented by fanduel
alongside kelly stewart peace and greg
ivory who are now
friends mikey my name is cabbie richards
mike see you guys later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you